[Music]
[Applause]
ancient civilizations possessed
knowledge that has been lost to time
i think that's obvious but to be fair
most lost knowledge is probably not
practical to us today anyway i mean who
cares what bacterial infection some
ancient swami cured with pine nuts and
prayer
when we could just use an antibiotic and
if some shaman or witch doctor
discovered how i can make windows not
update
the very second i start a zoom call well
i'd love to know that secret
but shaman are typically mac people so
not a problem for them but what about
ancient technologies that would be
of practical use today like levitation
specifically
levitating large heavy objects now that
would be useful many people believe
levitation specifically sound or
acoustic levitation
was how ancient civilizations like the
egyptians built the pyramids
there's actual science that supports
this let's find out why
[Music]
the ruins of several ancient
civilizations like the pyramids of giza
stonehenge in the uk and many others are
monuments constructed of
massive stones and the first question we
have to ask is
why why use huge ridiculously heavy
pieces of stone when the same structures
could have been made with smaller blocks
like
bricks yeah they were showing off but
we're looking at that question through
a modern lens based on the technologies
that are available to us
today we do know that sound can levitate
objects and i'll get into how that works
a little bit later
but current acoustic levitation
technology can only move
tiny objects with very little mass
nobody's building pyramids at mit
and if you are awesome some researchers
think ancient cultures may have mastered
levitation through sound
which allowed them to easily manipulate
massive objects
hokey religions and ancient weapons are
no match for a good blaster at your side
kid
yes the jedi weren't ancient culture but
let's look at cultures
in our own galaxy how the great pyramids
of egypt were built has been the subject
of debate for
a long time aliens the fact is no one
really knows for certain
how they were constructed how the aliens
know the mainstream theory is that it
took a workforce of about 5 000 men and
20 years to build the great pyramid
using ropes pulleys ramps and cranes and
that may very well be the case though
i have my doubts and if you guys want a
whole video on the construction of the
pyramids let me know in the comments
there's a lot to cover about pyramids
for example they weren't built by slaves
aliens don't need slaves can we can we
cool it with the aliens
for just a minute but let's talk about
the 10th century historian
abul hassan aliyamusudi he's known as
the herodotus of the arabs
and al-masudi traveled all over the
world but finally settled in egypt where
he wrote a 30-volume history of the
world
like everyone he was awestruck by the
pyramids
and he wrote a very intriguing passage
about how the giant stone blocks were
transported
first magic papyrus was imprinted with
symbols and placed under each stone
then the stone was struck with a metal
rod that caused it to slowly
rise above the ground the stone then
moved along a path that was paved with
other stones
and fenced in by metal poles the stone
traveled along this path for about 50
meters
then gently settled to the ground this
process was then repeated over and over
again until the builders had the stone
exactly where they wanted it
some believe metal poles could have been
used to create high frequency sound
vibrations
which would have been responsible for
creating the levitation effects
now given that the pyramids were already
thousands of years old when almasudi
wrote this
we have to wonder where he got his
information was this an oral history
passed down through the generations or
just a great story created by a talented
writer um
can i make a quick point go ahead may i
refer you to
clark's third law right clark's third
law says any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic bingo
the great pyramid of giza does possess
some extraordinary acoustic properties
and can dramatically amplify sounds at
certain frequencies
so the egyptians clearly knew a lot
about sound science
and how it could be used to produce
powerful effects possibly including
levitation
did striking the rock create vibrations
that resulted in sonic levitation
maybe the layout of stones and rods
created some kind of magnetic levitation
the science for either scenario is
sufficiently advanced
and therefore to al-masudi and to us
is indistinguishable from magic now the
pyramids aren't the only ancient
structures made of huge stone blocks
there are monuments around the world
that contain stone components
of such incredible size that they make
the pyramids look tiny but their
construction
remains a mystery let's look at a few
more
the temple of jupiter at balbeck lebanon
contains the three
largest stone blocks ever used in a
man-made structure
each block is estimated to weigh as much
as 1 000
tons now no industrial equipment in
existence today could lift one
no super crane and certainly no number
of people
yet somehow they are positioned together
so precisely
that a sheet of paper can't fit between
them now nearby is an
even bigger stone it's known as hajjar
el hibla and it's the largest piece of
stone
ever cut by humans it weighs 1200 tons
it's estimated it would take 16 000 men
to even
budget and it would be a huge challenge
of modern technology to just create it
yet
there it is how did they do it nobody
really knows
let's go to the other side of the planet
on a remote plateau in bolivia 12
000 feet above sea level there's a
monument called puerto del sol or gate
of the sun
this elaborately carved megalith is a
single piece of stone that weighs
10 tons cool well how did it end up
almost four kilometers
up a mountain and some scientists think
that it may not be in its original
location and if that's so where did it
come from
here's another nam adal is an
archaeological site on the island of
pompei and micronesia
and it's been called the machu picchu of
the pacific it's the only ancient city
ever built upon a coral reef the
engineering of non-medal is so complex
nobody can figure out how it was built
the lost city dates back to around 200
bc
and it's made up of hundreds of stacked
stone logs
each about three meters long and about a
meter in diameter
the logs which are stacked kind of like
firewood create walls that are 40 feet
high and 18 feet
thick that's taller than a three-story
building
yet each stone log weighs about two and
a half tons
and the logs that make up the high walls
they weigh as much as
50 tons each how they were moved and
lifted into position is
absolutely baffling the locals didn't
have pulleys they didn't have levers
they didn't even have access to metal
this is stone age technology so
how do they do it well the locals tell
stories
about giants who flew great canoes in
the sky aliens
and those aliens i mean giants
use some kind of magic to levitate the
logs into place now these are structures
from very different and diverse cultures
from all over the world
what was their secret well these
societies are so old
that there is no record of how these
structures were constructed but in
almost every culture where megaliths
exist
a legend also exists that the huge
stones were moved by sound
either by striking with a rod to produce
acoustic resonance
or by instruments or by simply chanting
stones into position
let's see how that works
for centuries travelers from the far
east told tales of acoustic levitation
some claim to have encountered mystics
who possess the ability to levitate
themselves
and objects using sound one famous story
comes from a medical doctor named dr
yall
he had been brought to a remote area of
tibet in 1939 to treat a buddhist holy
man suffering from an unknown illness
after spending some time with the monks
dr yao eventually gained their
confidence and to show their
appreciation
they performed a demonstration of sonic
levitation that left the good doctor
astounded
they took him to a meadow that was
surrounded by high cliffs and in the
middle of the clearing about 250 meters
from a cliff
was a heavy slab of stone then the monks
arranged 19 musical instruments
13 drums and 6 trumpets in a 90 degree
arc
around the stone and started playing the
other monks began singing
and chanting a prayer slowly increasing
the tempo
during the first four minutes nothing
happened then as the speed of the
drumming and the noise increased
the big stone blocks started to rock and
sway and suddenly took off
into the air and continued to rise until
it landed on a hilltop about 250 meters
above the
ground this demonstration was repeated
multiple times for dr yall who
actually took film footage of this what
where's the film
oh that's confiscated and classified
well that's a piece of
i know i actually found a paper that
explained scientifically how this
levitation might have actually worked
link below and if you're into geometry
and geodetics
you're gonna love it sounds moving
another creation credited with acoustic
levitation is the coral castle located
in florida the coral castle is a
sprawling stone compound
built by edward lead scalding between
the years 1923
and the complex is constructed of nearly
1 000 tons of rock which leads scalding
somehow cut
shaped lifted and maneuvered into place
all by himself
just him fyi he was five foot tall and
weighed 100 pounds
[Music]
i ruined the moment tonight elite
scalding refused to allow visitors or
observers on site while he was working
so there are no eyewitness accounts
detailing his construction methods
yet alone working mostly at night he was
somehow able to cut and transport
a thousand tons of rock to use for walls
and towers
he also built all kinds of buildings and
sculptures all from
giant pieces of stone an obelisk he
raised weighs
28 tons and the largest rock on the
property
weighs an estimated 35 tons now some of
these stones are twice the weight of the
largest blocks in the great pyramid of
giza
all this he did alone and without heavy
machinery the most amazing thing to me
is the stone gate it weighs nine tons
and has about a quarter inch of
clearance inside the frame
it's so well balanced that you could
push it open with a single
finger this is something that would be
challenging for even the most
experienced engineering and construction
team yet somehow leed skalnen was able
to do it alone
oh this guy definitely wasn't union nope
leedskalnin never specifically
identified sound as a key factor in his
work
but he had an interest in radio and
owned all kinds of sound equipment which
he used for
unknown purposes now no one ever saw him
lift enormous objects
though the story goes that spying
teenagers saw him float coral blocks
through the air like
hydrogen balloons i love this guy i do
too
i have discovered the secrets of the
pyramids
and here found out how the egyptians and
the ancient builders in peru
yucatan and asia have this only
primitive tools
raised in set-in-place blocks of stone
weighing
many tons he told friends ancient
masters had developed a method for
overcoming the force of gravity
and that as a practicing freemason he
was exposed to this knowledge through
his contacts in that secret organization
this guy built an illuminati sand castle
with magnets
you might have with magnets or sound or
both
i mean there's actual science behind
some of this
unless you're in a vacuum sound is
everywhere sound is created by vibrating
molecules of a medium like air or water
into waves the waves hit our eardrums or
our skull and our brain decodes the
wavelengths
into sound we don't usually think of
sound as having a physical presence but
acoustic waves can absolutely affect the
environment
think of a nightclub or a concert where
you could just you could feel the bass
or how ultrasound is used to pulverize
kidney stones
or how singing the right note or
wavelength with a sufficient volume or
amplitude can shatter glass
there are even sound waves that can make
people sick we've got a video coming up
on this so hit subscribe hit the bell
don't don't over sell it i'm sorry i i i
get excited
anyway current acoustic levitation
techniques use sound traveling through
media
usually gas to counteract the force of
gravity a basic acoustic levitator has
two main parts
a transducer which is really just the
surface that creates the sound by
vibrating kind of like a speaker
and there's also a reflector which helps
focus the sound waves on the object you
want to levitate now to get this to work
there's quite a bit of math involved
for example the distance between the
transducer and the reflector
must be a multiple of half of the
wavelength of the sound
this is because you need to get enough
molecules lined up under the object in
order to lift it
if you just blast sound in an object all
you're doing is scattering a bunch of
molecules around
that won't work but if we remember the
story about the tibetan monks
they were using this precise technique
they played specific instruments
in unison just like a transducer focused
at a specific
object from a specific distance like a
reflector
i bet if we knew the actual sounds of
their instruments we'd see a correlation
between the wavelengths they emitted and
the distance to the stone
now i'm not saying the monks actually
got this to work but i am saying
the science is sound
so now that we've seen that sound can be
used to move objects
is this enough evidence to prove how the
pyramids were constructed
for some people yes for most no for me
i'm not really sure could the pyramids
have been constructed using pulleys
ramps and cranes
like mainstream egyptologists claim well
sure
but when you look at the sheer size
those ramps would need to be
and the distances involved the amount of
materials required to build the
scaffolding would be more than the
material in the actual pyramids
much more so where where all the
construction materials
to me there seems like there's something
going on here but we can't even
talk about this without being labeled
kooks any challenge of established
scientific dogma
is labeled pseudoscience isn't that a
bit arrogant
i mean isn't pseudoscience only
pseudoscience until it's
actual science but people are afraid to
go up against the establishment
kepler and copernicus were ridiculed by
their peers louis pasteur's research was
rejected by the medical establishment
gregor mendel nikola tesla
initially they were rejected imagine the
hate they'd get if twitter existed
but that's a long time ago surely we've
matured since then
think about this in 1903 when the wright
brothers and others were building
airplanes
the new york times said manned flight
would not be possible for 1 to 10
million years oops and in 1985
the new york times said no matter how
inexpensive or powerful a laptop
computer would become
nobody would want one no boy and when
apple announced the iphone
the time said they'd probably never
build it and even if they did
nobody would buy it and speaking of
twitter
here's what the new york times said when
it launched using twitter for
literate communication is about as
likely as firing up a
cb radio and hearing some guy recite the
iliad
whether the service could be made into a
sustainable business quite
unknown i'm skeptical
haven't i always told you don't trust
the media you have
if you suggest that levitating heavy
objects with sound
or creating free energy is even possible
you're viciously attacked
not just by facebook and twitter but by
the new york freaking times
aren't new ideas worth exploring did
steve jobs care what people thought
about him
does elon musk care no they just went
out and changed the world
so my message today is not to the
corporate media or social media
they make money by getting all of us to
attack each other that's their business
model it's shameful and that's why
nobody trusts them
who cares george bernard shaw said all
great truths
begin as blasphemies this message is to
those blasphemers
to the recluse out there building
castles with sound
and magnets and his own hands to the
nerd in the garage tinkering with
electronics because he knows in his
heart
there is a better way this message is to
the next kepler
jobs elon musk to the misfits and
dreamers and visionaries my message is
to you
they are going to attack you they are
going to hate you
ignore them keep dreaming keep building
keep blaspheming because i can tell you
with 100
certainty the world needs you
much more than it needs the new york
times
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything today help me out
with the algorithm and comment
like subscribe share the algorithm is a
gorgon with hair made of venomous snakes
that could turn you into stone
but with your help we can defeat her i
eat gorgonz for breakfast
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
[Music]
so
you